great to be here in Los Angeles
California we had a lot of fun thanks to
and I forget the guys name thanks to the
guy who made that master class clip
which I posted on YouTube if you
listened to the last podcast I spent a
fair amount of time illuminating the
grift that is master class this scam
where essentially they get people that
you love and respect and admire they get
geniuses to come and con you in your own
home through YouTube it's like the final
insult you know it's like these people
that you love and that you've watched
their movies and you've watched their
comedy they hand them boatloads of money
to set up a class where they tell you
all of the wisdom that they have learned
in their career and you I guess through
osmosis take that wisdom in and do with
it who knows what we don't know that's
the point nobody has really gone that
far yet do you become David Lynch I
don't know maybe you're just interested
in filmmaking and instead of buying a
book you go to a master class I would be
totally cool with this if it was people
that were just interested in topics I
don't think that's what it is I think
there's a lot of people out there like
my mother who's a schizophrenic when
when I would watch her at night after
midnight
QVC the home shopping network that that
whole they take the gloves off when it
comes to marketing after midnight they
know they know with their marketing to
after 12:00 a.m.
QVC just starts throwing [ __ ] out of
people they come out and they're like
this is Jacqueline Kennedy's engagement
we're like crazy [ __ ] that isn't true
and my mother would sit in her chair
with her phone out and scribbling into a
notebook writing down the numbers of all
of these things and then calling up and
spending just charging she didn't have
any money she was charging on QVC so I
think a lot of those people will be
purchasing masterclass I think that's
the demo I don't think the demos
rational people that
appreciate another artform I think the
demo is people that tweet it marvel
they're like let me direct the next one
I've seen that I've seen people tweet it
marvel hey let me get in there let me
get in there and direct the next movie
in your billion-dollar franchise these
are people that live amongst you some of
them aren't trolls it's easy to think
everyone's a troll they're not there's
some genuine lunatics walking the earth
there's this guy on Facebook I know I'm
not gonna say his name but he's clearly
unwell and he would tweet at Marvel like
put me in the gets in he would tweet a
very serious thing and you're like and
then you look at the rest of his stuff
you're like oh it's obvious he's not a
troll and you know but master class so I
was [ __ ] on master class even though
a lot of people that I respect are doing
it and I would also do it this is what I
don't ever want you people to not get
about me and about what I preach
if master class came to me with $400
okay now they went to all these other
people with a lot of money but if they
came to me with like 400 a month just a
few pokeballs essentially and I had to
come and hit you people over the head I
would absolutely do it you would see me
smiling and I'd go well the thing about
comedy and podcasting is the tapes all
autre done I don't need a lot of money
they could convince me so easily could
just pull me in a room and go listen
[ __ ] these people that's all they'd have
to say and I go you're right you're
right what am i oh yeah they go what are
you a [ __ ] schoolboy get in there
teach a master class I don't give a [ __ ]
you people really the majority of you
don't deserve a government you don't you
don't deserve a entertainment industry
you don't so the idea that you you don't
deserve to be dealt with honestly you
deserve masterclass that's what you get
that's what you get so if they came to
me I would feel shitty about it for a
half a second and then they'd write a
check and I would [ __ ] dance my fat
ass in that [ __ ] YouTube room
and I would spout whatever garbage I
would say join the Platinum tier be an
Excelsior member of the master class do
you want the real good wisdom and so
just know that know that I'm not I'm not
a saint here which you know